also ich will seine macht zu tun ich
habe
hast du gemüse oder so erwarte ich mir
noch ein paar sachen kräften kommen wir
ein haus aussieht ein komisches stelzen
ich nur meine exzellenten bogenschießen
skills lipper weg braucht im zu unter
beweis zu stellen in trouble main will
dahin steht immer dann packt fall noch
mitten in der landschaft den bald fertig
naja kenne ich irgendwo her auf jeden
fall ein spitzhacken und schaufeln die
zwei schaufeln
mit 2 3 1 2 ich war mir immer veganes
brot und da beschwert man ja auch noch
nicht kaputt ist kann ich dass die kiste
schmeißen ingo ich glaube eiskanal seien
von einem kanal
das mache ich so dass ich andere sind
deswegen darauf bauen dass zusätzliche
kosten auf denkt an all diesen sachen
halt so wachse ilco gameplay von life sa
so ich nehme auch noch reisen mit damit
ich mir in der höhle vielleicht noch ein
paar sachen machen kann wenn wir länger
drin sind ich habe jetzt genug essen
dabei ich habe so einige sachen dabei
ich würde einfach mal sagen einmal in
der schmiede bist du also ich bin bereit
ich bin auch bereit finden der ich bin
in unserer stadt gut treffens der stadt
lasse meine richtung gehen dass er gar
nicht hingegangen ja wir gehen feiern
statt aus dem neuen recht okay ja ich
zeig dir was ich meine
was ich meine hier oben mit dem turm ist
mein favorit ist schon wo es hingeht
erstens kombi vor der tür wartete bei
rüdiger ich schlag den ich habe auch für
dich das schenke ich dir danke sehr
so lasst uns mal da lang gehen sollte da
lang
hier ok aufbruch in eine neue welt
hier hört jetzt ein neues lied was zu
unserer reise passt genau erhoben
eigentlich dieses bestimmt harz oder
sowas hatte ich brauche einfach mal ab
ok guck mal das ist ihnen das in diesen
sachen job okay okay
das darf nur mit dem kescher abbauen und
im ketchup und mayonnaise ketchup ok
sonstig kräften kraft kletterberg hier
auf dem berg rüber du okay kraft
schaffen wir das schaffen wir mal kurz
was das hier für den erzkörper also
kupfer
ja ja das ist ja das für dieser saison
aus der rüstung draußen mal wo ich mich
mal sehen wie das aussieht jetzt habe
ich schon abgebaut
wie sah anders aus es war so einfach so
orange wie man sich das vorstellt
was hast du angst doch gebaut da ist das
land ist dass das feuer schnell da durch
bin dass der ganze berg hoch das ist
abartig ach so arbeitet kennen wir schon
von apathie der hat man immer ganz viel
appetit darauf
jaja brand oder was hab ich nehme die
ganze kohle immer mit weil dafür geht
man mittlerweile ja auch
erfahrungspunkte
das ist natürlich sehr sinnvoll ich habe
hier herzlich level ich will unbedingt
mal was den schaden relativ valentinstag
aber auch noch kohle so hier ist wieder
so ein doofes alter was sind das bitte
für millionen hier
diesmal war das sind junge männer im
anzug richtig richtig fetten bäumen ok
ich will sagen aufbruch in den dschungel
wollen uns einfach jeder baum damit
einfach untergraben bugs heute kurz ich
mache ein screenshot von unserem
dschungel mach das jetzt sagen jeder
nimmt sich zum baum und klebt sich an
diesem baum runtergekommen wie leicht
und neun und liegen dabei eine rolle
dies ist eine kleine baum
na gut die sind menge wieder richtig
kriegt man auch ein bisschen was zu
essen und auch ein paar xp ich bin aber
veganer so was mal hat es ist sicher
dann hast du das mal ich hab gerade noch
cola jetzt egal wo du runter fällt es
ihnen was hält dich immer auf auch hier
sind auch noch so kakaobohnen die kamera
mitnehmen
oh ja da man uns sondern kakaoplantagen
kekse backen glaube ich aber wer hat ist
eine gute idee
damit können wir die kekse auf so
witzige sachen rheinischen sie mal was
machst du da machst du ich mag es nicht
okay zum reinkommen
hier geht es einfach mal hier rein o die
auswahl lässt es bleiben
das geile ein tempel ich bin g aff
expedition stoner
das ist deswegen finde ich dieses viel
zu wie es auch geil weil hier
ich glaube ich habe etwas gefunden im
dschungel oma sich das mal genauer an
eine lagune lassen zwar da unten rein
gehen gucken
so ein komischer diamant also nicht die
amazon und links komisches herr harris
treffen
der crafter ich habe das gefühl obst
obst gefühl wenn es hier ein graben
dann stoßen wir auf ein typischer höhle
glaub ich nicht da ich tappe ich habe im
gefühl dass wir uns hier gerade unter da
müssen hier genau ich gerade hell war
das denn
nein das ist einfach ein gefühl
irgendwie sowas wie eine tagesreise mixa
habe schon die benutze ich hab noch nie
ist es vielleicht wirklich ernst auch
ironisch sachen sage ich hab noch nie
aber ich geh programmheft nicht weil ich
hab keinen druck das zu installieren und
mehr so sonja werd ich hasste runden wo
leute goebels prozent
keine ahnung das witzig weil auch sie
erschrecken und darin die fäden laufen
sowie bei denen sonst nicht richtig geil
ja da und das habe ich gefunden
hahaha grünes toll aber keiner will das
zeigt hier müssen weiter da noch mehr
nukleare solches zeug
ich gehe doch überzeugt wieder erfahrung
es gibt richtig viel erfahrung ins zeug
das ist also erst ich habe eine höhle
gefunden ja gewusst dass wir unser
wohlbefinden jetzt sagt das war mein
verdienst tag ist eine slava nächste
aufhelle höhle ist nur ein raum
aber wir werden schon im anschluss
finden sagt ich habe uns dahin geführt
darum it dienste eingeführt immer nach
rechts
sollte wie la vie zu kriegen da silva
glaube ich ja erst mal dazu redstone
gehweg aber dass silbereisen ist dass
ich hab ihn gefunden das ist tenor in
nagano auch schon voll viel okay doch
das bringt nicht so hektisch da müssen
wir müssen weiter wir müssen die höhle
weiter irgendwo lang keine ahnung ich
auf den weg von vorhin warst contractor
hier unten drunter war ein green saphir
ich weiß jetzt dass es bringt doch
saphir ist geil
davon kann sich sachen machen du kannst
dir damit sowas wie eisen wohl besser
glaube ich dann kannst du auch so
werkzeuge machen ist auf jeden fall cool
ok oh hallo hallo herr klawitter nabu
spitzenwert der bobo ist was auch hier
fliegt über allerdings runterklappen
merkel mehr als zweiter durch den
dschungel geht damit leute sollen sachen
zusammen machen ja auch lustig in summe
zu gehen aber ich habe das gefühl das
wäre ganz nach vor einem neuen fall
stehen wegen des hauses gefunden
letzter das ist chips schrittweise
rubinrote geil
damit hängen auslöser machen mobil jetzt
hast du das zufällig nicht zufällig
fackeln oder so doch habe ich richtig
vorbereitet wie sonst was ich habe ich
habe schon geil dann hab ich da erkennen
so eine spitze gemacht ich hab die sonne
nicht so viel ich weiß ja probieren gut
ist können die kommentare schreiben
während 1616 fackeln habe ich jetzt bei
mir ist es gerade dunkel wie sowas sonst
hat sich lohnt auch unter zu gehen und
hier noch mehr von diesen grünen zeugen
so viel apple vom krieg warte ich mal
jetzt abbauen bitte ok sind zwei dem
landesrecht du du hast die erfahrung
bekommen haha wie schnell 50 e-mail
neuen bonner ich bin 32
ich hab so leuchten des bundestags von
weißen nicht viel wert auf einem
schlimmste richtig viel gefunden
natürlich noch mal richtig viel raus
habe ich jetzt darauf gefunden
ich habe sowieso blaues leuchtendes
aluminium ich hab noch mehr aluminium
woher die kalorien wie viel erfahrung
das wort schaut was ich habe strotzt nur
so von ärzten habe ich glaub in höhe des
allgemeinen noch mehr wir haben uns
einfach nur durch gänge durch wirklich
gemeinsam durch irgendein beim aufnehmen
relativ doof ich würds angerichtet hat
dann lasst uns das ist einer stelle
zusammen hochgekommen kino ich gerade
bin geht mich herum drüber ich glaube
hier kommen wir schnell raus und hab ich
habe jetzt mal wieder den weg zurück
also ich hab ich mich da wo wir noch
nicht so weit von entfernt
ok so treffen uns wieder dann der lagune
witzige sie davor an der red lake der
google-gründer spongebob schwammkopf
drei stunden später recht den ich so
lange zeit später das mit den alten
reporter ersetzen musste und einen neuen
einstellen mussten
das gab's aber hängen da habe ich auch
viel über richtig gut da hab ich das
spongebob humor aus ist nacht
nein wer sich alleine zu zweit ich sehe
ich aber nicht
falls uns allein ich sehe das haus von
rüdiger ott ist 329 meter entfernt ich
bin ich würde sagen wenn wir uns finden
dschungel wird auf die ganze zeit im
dschungel ziellos herum dass eine gute
story ja das werden wir so dass finden
ich versuche ich grad hoch zu bauen
aber irgendwie da ich klettere ist
erklärt hatte einen baum hoch und
schaffte es nicht und kratzer ab und
ging wieder und habe ihr mann einer
episch kommentiert der glückskette das
ans brett oder ausgegraben hat komplette
rüst und freunde dreht er kenne kein
schaden
ich möchte aber trotzdem hat einfach mal
alles aus einfach um zu schauen könnte
da nicht sonst noch nirgendwo etwas
interessantes auf uns warten
man weiss essen jenes aber gerade nicht
zu der fall
ich versuche jetzt hoch zu kommen aber
ich bin immer wieder von ärzte
aufgehalten mich runter drücken